y vamos a seguir explorando todos estos
métodos para resolver sistemas de
ecuaciones y en esta ocasión quiero ver
el método de suma y resta o de
eliminación es el mismo y bueno para
esto voy a tomar dos ecuaciones la
ecuación 3x 4 james igualdad 2.5 y la
ecuación 5x menos 4 james esto igual a
25.5 a 25.5 y bueno recuerda que lo que
estoy buscando es un plan ordenado xy
que cumpla ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente por si lo vemos de una
manera gráfica la intersección de las
dos rectas de una manera gráfica cada
una de estas ecuaciones representa una
recta y lo que estaría buscando la
intersección de estas dos rectas
ahora bien pensemos un poco en esta
ecuación que tengo de amarillo lo que
quiero preguntarme yo en un principio es
si a esta ecuación de amarillo le puedo
sumar o restar algo de tal manera que me
quede una ecuación con solamente una
incógnita y la respuesta no parece tan
trivial porque porque si yo agarro algo
que tenga que ver con xy se lo sumo se
lo restó esta ecuación me va a seguir
creando una ecuación que tenga que ver
con x y con gem bueno
pero qué va a pasar si en lugar de
pensar en un término que tenga que ver
con xy con que sumamos mejor otra
ecuación sumamos estas dos ecuaciones de
tal manera que se cancele todo lo que
tenga que ver con james es decir lo que
voy a hacer lado derecho es sumar estas
dos expresiones mientras que el lado
izquierdo voy a sumar estas dos
cantidades y por lo tanto me queda una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita sé
que esto no parece nada obvio sin
embargo ahorita que resolvamos este
ejercicio te va a quedar mucho más claro
y seguramente vas a decir oye sal qué te
pasa como esta es lo que puede sumar
ecuaciones y bueno es que realmente velo
de la siguiente manera si tenemos una
ecuación de la forma x más bella igual a
cero tenemos una ecuación y yo le agrego
de ambos lados lo mismo entonces la
igualdad se mantiene es decir si yo sumo
o restó en la misma cantidad de ambos
lados supongamos de entonces como
sabemos que desigualdad de la igualdad
se mantiene y me quedaría a x + 20 más
de esto es igual a c + tema y se sigue
cumpliendo esta igualdad es decir que si
hacemos la misma operación de un lado de
la ecuación
para que se mantenga la igualdad tenemos
que hacer la misma operación del otro
lado de la ecuación esto ya lo hemos
visto varias veces así que regresando
esta idea si yo tengo aquí dos
ecuaciones ya la primera ecuación le
suma la segunda ecuación realmente lo
que estoy diciendo es que del lado
izquierdo voy a sumar 5 x menos 4 y
james y del lado derecho voy a sumar
25.5 y en este momento es cuando tú te
debes de preguntar pero estas dos
expresiones son equivalentes la
respuesta es que si 5 x menos 4 y es
igual a 25.5 porque esto es lo que nos
dice la otra ecuación por lo tanto como
5x menos 4 y es igual a 25.5 lo que
estoy sumando del lado izquierdo es
igual a lo que estoy sumando del lado
derecho y es justo por eso que mi
igualdad se conserva así que vamos a
hacerlo 3 x 5 x es 8 x 4 y menos 4 y
estos dos se eliminan si te das cuenta
son operaciones contrarias tengo 4 jeff
y después le quito 4 y pues estos dos se
cancelan se van o me dan 0 es como si
tuviera 000 yen pues es lo mismo que 0 8
x + cero james es igual a 2.5 más
5.5 lo cual es 28 y aquí quiero que te
des cuenta que ya tengo una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita 8x igual a 28
una ecuación bastante fácil de resolver
porque si yo divido entre 8 ambos lados
de la ecuación me queda que x es igual a
28 entre 8 en lo cual ya es un resultado
numérico 28 entre 8 es lo mismo que 7
medios o 3.57 entre 2 es 3.5 y ya tengo
un valor para x como lo encontré sumando
estas dos ecuaciones porque suma estas
dos ecuaciones me di cuenta que me iba a
quedar con una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita y bueno ahora que tengo el
valor de x voy a sustituir este valor en
alguna de las dos ecuaciones para
encontrar el valor de yemen y mejor voy
a tomar la primera actuación entonces me
queda 3 que multiplica x pero x vale 7
medios 3 por 7 medios más 4 james esto
tiene que ser igual a 2.5 estoy
sustituyendo el valor de x para
encontrar mi valor de james y el 2.5 lo
voy a escribir como 5 medios para que
todo viva en el mundo de las fracciones
y ahora sí vamos a despejar allí
entonces me queda 3
medios 21 24 y esto es igual a 5 medios
y ahora voy a restar de ambos lados de
la ecuación 21 medios aquí voy a restar
21 medios hay que restar 21 medios de
tal manera que estos dos se van a
cancelar y de la búsqueda realmente me
queda 4 y en estos dos se van y después
del lado derecho me queda 5 medios menos
21 medios lo cual es menos 16 medios
menos 16 medios que es lo mismo que
bueno déjame ponerlo así primero menos
16 medios menos 16 medios muy bien y
ahora como ya no tengo mucho espacio voy
a agarrar otro color y voy a seguir acá
4 james es igual a quien ojo aquí estoy
escribiendo la continuación y 16 medios
es lo mismo que 8 entonces nos queda 4
igual a menos 8 y dividiendo ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 4 me queda que es
igual a menos 2 y perfecto entonces ya
tengo que la solución es x igual a 7
medios y igual a menos 2 o el punto de
la intersección de estas dos rectas es
el punto 7 medios como al menos 2 y
bueno sería muy bueno verificar que
cumplen ambas ecuaciones vamos a
intentarlo para la ecuación de abajo al
menos para quedarnos con
seguridad tengo 5 que multiplica a x 4 y
igual a 25.55 por 7 medios es 35 medios
ya esto le tengo que quitar menos 2 por
4 lo cual es menos 8 y cuánto es esto 35
medios que es 17.5 más 8 esto es igual a
25.5 si funciona esta ecuación 35 medios
es 17.5 y esto le sumó 8 me da 25.5 así
que ahora vamos a resolver un problema
que tenga que ver con un sistema de
ecuaciones y que a este sistema de
ecuaciones lo resolvamos por el método
de eliminación o de suma y resta así que
qué dice el problema nadie y pedro
visitan una tienda de dulces nadie
cumplió tres chocolates y cuatro gomitas
por 2.84 pesos pedro por su parte compró
también tres chocolates pero a él sólo
le alcanzó para una gomita y se gastó un
peso con 79 centavos cuánto vale cada
chocolate y cada gomita en esta tienda
de dulces y bueno lo primero que vamos a
hacer es bautizar variables así que me
voy a tomar de nuevo xy james y
o sea x el precio de cada chocolate y se
hay en el precio de cada una de las
gomitas así que déjame ponerlo james es
el precio de cada una de las gomitas y
bueno ahora que ya tengo cada una de mis
variables definidas pues ahora vamos a
pensar en hacer las ecuaciones y qué
ecuaciones tengo digo tres veces si yo
compro tres chocolates y además compró
cuatro gomitas me gasto dos pesos con 84
centavos por lo tanto 3 x 3 por el
puesto de cada uno de los chocolates más
4 porque compré 4 gomitas por el precio
de cada una de las gomitas esto tiene
que ser igual a 2.84 bueno esto lo que
nos dice la primera oración y esto fue
lo que compró nadie ojo
estamos hablando de nadie ahora vamos a
hablar de pedro pedro compró también
tres chocolates por lo tanto 3 x 3 por
el precio de cada uno de los chocolates
pero a él solamente le alcanzó para
comprar una gomita por lo tanto mayer
esto tiene que ser igual a 1
79 y digo una gomita por el precio de lo
que costó cada una de las gomitas y
fíjate que ya con esto tengo escritas
mis dos ecuaciones que por cierto
podemos resolver de varios métodos con
el método de suma y resta que es cómo lo
vamos a resolver o sustitución o método
gráfico y bueno de hecho si lo que se
hace por método gráfico necesitarías
tener como un ojo de águila pero bueno
vamos a resolverlo con el método de suma
y resta y para esto lo que quiero
preguntarte es a esta ecuación que tengo
aquí arriba a la primera ecuación
existirá algo que le podamos sumar o en
dado caso restar a esta ecuación de tal
manera que se elimine una de estas dos
variables y la respuesta es que sí
si nosotros agarramos la segunda
ecuación y la restamos de la primera
ecuación se va a cancelar la equis
porque 3 x menos x
esto nos va a hacer que todo lo que
tenga que ver con x se cancele entonces
del lado izquierdo voy a restar 3 x más
bien mientras que el lado derecho voy a
restar 1.79 y puedo hacer eso tan fácil
la respuesta es que sí porque estas dos
cosas son iguales recuerda que tenemos
aquí una igualdad
que 3x más que es igual a 1.79 y por lo
tanto lo que estoy haciendo de un lado
de la ecuación lo voy a hacer también
del otro lado de la ecuación así que
déjame poner que un menos y voy a restar
espera espera mejor no voy a poner aquí
menos que multiplica su vez a 3x magem
esto es lo que voy a restar del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación y bueno esto es
lo mismo que menos 3 x menos james
entonces menos 3 x menos james esto es
lo que voy a restar del lado izquierdo
mientras que del lado derecho voy a
restar 1.79 y ojo recuerda que puedo
hacer esto porque yo sé que estas dos
expresiones son iguales esto es lo que
me dice la segunda ecuación y por lo
tanto ya puedo restar los y cuantos esto
déjame poner esto por aquí bueno de
hecho otra forma de ver los que están
multiplicando la ecuación de abajo por
menos uno la estamos multiplicando
entera por menos uno para que tú puedas
aplicar el método de suma y resta y
ahora sí que me queda de este lado tengo
3x menos 3x pues estas dos cosas se van
3 x 2 3 x 0 x pero pues 0 x x no es nada
por lo tanto se cancelan y después me
queda 4 y menos
4 - es lo mismo que 3 bien bueno eso es
lo que pasa del lado izquierdo mientras
que el lado derecho que va a pasar
tengo 2.84 menos 1.79 cuánto es esto
pues como el de arriba es más grande me
queda 1 punto y 79 para 84 es 5 entonces
1.053 y es igual a 1.05 ahora qué pasa
si yo divido ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 3 voy a obtener el valor
de james y ya es igual a 1 punto 0 53 1
entre 3 aquí no me cabe ninguna vez bajo
el 1 y después tengo 10 aquí me va a
quedar un 1 y aquí un 0 10 entre 3 cabe
3 veces 3 por 3 9 10 menos 9 esto es lo
mismo que 1 bajo ahora el 5 y me queda a
15 entre 315 entre 13 5 entonces 5 por 3
15 y bueno ya que no me queda nada
15 - 15 estos 00 y ya sé cuánto vale
james
llévales 0.35 es decir cada una de las
gomitas vale 0.35 centavos perfecto ya
tengo el valor de james
y una vez que ya obtuve el valor de y
recuerda no hemos acabado el problema
ahora lo que necesitamos saber es el
valor de x y como tengo el valor de x
bueno me puedo fijar en cualquiera de
estas dos ecuaciones y de aquí despejar
a x entonces me voy a fijar en la
ecuación de abajo que decía 3 x + james
es igual a 1.79 y después voy a
sustituir el valor de james yerbales
0.35 entonces me va a quedar 3 x + 0.35
esto es igual a 1.79 y si restó 0.35 de
ambos lados de la ecuación que me queda
bueno del lado izquierdo solamente me va
a quedar 3 x porque 0.35 menos 0.35 se
van se cancelan y del lado derecho me
queda un 1.79 menos 0.35 esto es lo
mismo que 1.44 5 para 94 3 para 74 y
bajamos el 1 1.44 y bueno ahora lo voy a
dividir entre 3 para sacar el valor de x
así que vamos a hacerlo 1.44 entre 3 me
queda 0 veces x 0 bajo un 1 pongo un
punto y bajo el 4 14 cabe cuatro veces
en 3
4 x 3 es 12 después de aquí hago la
resta no me cabe pero lo voy a hacer acá
14 - 12 es 2 y después bajo el 4 y aquí
me queda 8 8 por 3 24 perfecto ya con
este tema el valor de x x es igual a
0.48 x vale 0.48 pesos y ya con esto
puedo poner las respuestas el precio de
cada uno de los chocolates es de 48
centavos y el precio de cada uno de las
gomitas es de 35 centavos de 0.35 pesos